hey guys how's it goin today it's gonna
be a really wild day I'm off to get a
haircut I might do something crazy every
time I go to get my hair done I have all
these crazy ideas and then I end up not
doing anything
these are my size
oh no it's raining uh I just got my hair
done can you guys tell the difference
what where did this rain come from it's
Los Angeles this doesn't this doesn't
happen James I'm starving I need to get
home
Oh
it's my arrow
I got a lens for this camera it looks
good I'm bringing you a brand new video
today today I'm bringing you a brand new
video where are you trying to vlog with
this camera now no I'm just gonna be
shooting a video I had a dream that I
got a bunch of dogs and I rescued them
and I couldn't love them all enough and
I didn't have enough love for them so I
woke up crying and then I just like I
went and I smuggled Maddy nice and I
love you baby boy it was the saddest
thing ever I couldn't believe it I cried
I cried
I'm waiting for my acai bowl to be
delivered oh he's cute the bull is here
or they forgot to put all of the fruits
in it though but whatever mmm you love
her now let me get to work
I am not sure but I think the audio
might have been messed up in the
beginning of this video
this was the microphone I was using and
I'm not sure why they did that to me so
I switched hey you guys second Yerba
open it up what is it lighting is yeah
hey frenchie late was it from open it up
thanks Jason Estelle did you run to get
your cell bud you bought it oh it's
wrapped in a bowl okay pull the red one
you're stronger than that oh you really
love style
see hardcore Justine what is this it's
gonna like shock me or something what is
this it's an arm are you a robot yes
what is this it's the truth yeah I
wanted to tell you all that I am NOT
real what is this this my new arm what
is it
it's from the movie hardcore Henry
you're no fun
what the hell is card for Henry it's all
shot in first-person view this is the
dude's arm they had access from the
movie dear Justine take my hand and go
on the most fun and hardcore ride of
your life
Mady look yeah I feel like we're gonna
hand full of fun with us okay all right
so concert now so I'll see you later bye
so the concert that I went to last night
was a guy named well his band name is
Eden it was a great show it was in Los
Angeles he's from Ireland now I'm
drinking some yerba mate' again not
sponsored I actually went to their
website through the day just to order
some more and I was looking at the
reviews of this product and a bunch of
you guys had left reviews saying oh my
god I heard about this from I just seen
I just seen suggest the drink those and
it's really good
it is really good not sponsored not
sponsored I swear to god it is not they
did once a few years ago if you guys
remember watching a vlog they sent me a
year supply of it how lasted me three
months I also gave a bunch of my friends
and anytime I have people over they
would always end up just taking it from
me so clearly a year supply of this did
not last me a year I've been meaning to
shoot an ask IJ video but I haven't had
the I was noticing at the time to shoot
it but I've definitely had the time but
the motivation to shoot the video
I could not force myself to do it this
week I was in struggle City YouTube I
feel like for me it comes in waves
wow I'm super motivated I really want to
make youtube videos I'm loving it I'm
having so much fun - I have to make a
video I have to shoot this so for me if
I don't feel like making a youtube video
it's something that I don't want to
force myself to do that going back and
watching some videos where I know that
my heart isn't in making that video to
me it's it feels obvious and I feel like
some of you guys it might also feel
obvious I don't like to take you too
seriously I like to have fun with it I'd
like it to be something that even though
technically it is my job I don't want it
to feel like a job because when
something feels like a job it can suck
the life out of you so no matter what
job you're doing even if it is a job
that you're not enjoying try to find a
way to enjoy doing that job or if you're
in the position to quit that job and go
and live your
your passion of whatever it is that you
want to do do it I know I've said this
many times before but even starting
making YouTube videos back in the day
when I did quit my job it was something
that I should not have done but I just
knew that doing what I was doing my
heart wasn't in it and for me you know
creating content and working for someone
else who didn't appreciate the work that
I was doing it was by far the worst
thing ever so I had to get out and for a
few years maybe more than a few years it
was pretty rough but I feel like for me
and for a lot of you guys if you want to
do something bad enough you can
definitely do it and I cannot stress
that enough to you guys anyway I just
need to editing this video and I felt
like it wasn't long enough so I just
wanted to add a little hello and a
goodbye to it so I hope that you guys
have a wonderful weekend
happy Friday let me know also in the
comments below of some videos that you'd
like me to shoot whether it's a
challenge video or if you have some
questions for that ask IJ episode that I
do plan on shooting this week or if you
just want to say hi feel free to do that
I'll see you guys in the next video bye
my eyelashes are so long alright what
did you make these today oh I need a boo
boo already was